nancy pelosi just censured a republican
representative
paul gosar so his party line vote and
and they're censuring paul gosar because
he sent out some spicy tweets or
something you know
he did the sort of thing that dems do
all the time but he did it he's a
republican so they're going to censure
him
lauren bobert another
firebrand conservative member of
congress came out in defense
of congressman gosar democrat policies
are so pathetic and have done so poorly
that the left has nothing else to do
patrol the internet looking for ways to
get offended and then try to target
members and strip them other committees
this is a dumb waste of the house's time
but since
the speaker has designated the floor to
discuss members inappropriate actions
shall we
the jihad squad member from minnesota
has paid her husband and not her brother
husband the other one over a million
dollars in campaign funds this member is
allowed on the foreign affairs committee
while praising terrorists
a democrat chairwoman incited further
violence in the streets outside of a
courthouse and then the cherry on top
my colleague and three-month
presidential candidate from california
who is on the intelligence committee
slept with fang fang a chinese spy let
me say that again a member of congress
who receives classifieds
sleeping with the enemy this is
unacceptable
i love it i love it
jihad squad member ilhan omar was
illegally or certainly crookedly paying
off her husband not her brother husband
by the way the other husband oh my gosh
stop it stop it they're already dead
stop it don't keep kicking them while
they're down uh eric swalwell was
sleeping with fang fang a chinese spy
she's never denied
oh my gosh
i love it been a long day it's been a
long
month
it's been a long year or a year and a
half and when you're just so exhausted
i'm telling you one of the great
constellations in the world
is just flopping onto your helix
mattress when you get home helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else with
helix you're getting a mattress that you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep they've got soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress you're
matched to mattress comes right to your
door ship for free they got a 10 year
warranty
you get to try it yourself for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you are
going to love it they got great
financing options flexible payment plans
so a great night of sleep is never far
away helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com knowles
that's 200 bucks off and two free
pillows at helixsleep.com
knowles there are going to be very
sophisticated republicans
who are at very prestigious think tanks
and
stodgy dusty institutions they're gonna
say this is not right this is not no
don't do this we're better than that
don't no don't make all these jokes
about all these degenerate democrat
members of congress it's so no i think
it's it's funny it's funny it's just
it's jokes and the jokes have a basis in
reality because ilhan omar really does
have a kind of strange personal history
and she actually has praised terrorists
and laughed and said 911 is some people
did something hahaha and
she says i'll call you done she kind of
giggles and laughs on camera we have all
of this eric swallow really did sleep
with a chinese spy that actually did
happen
so basis in reality it's funny
the attacks on republican members of
congress like paul ghost are completely
disingenuous it's a complete double
standard and we should mock them
relentlessly i just there's a little
rhetorical
lesson in this that lauren bobert is
teaching us
if she had been timid and said you know
ilhan omar i'm not sure she's very loyal
to this country i'm not i just think she
the way she's talked about some foreign
terror groups it's not if if you if you
went
into that kind of an attack with that
timidity
of a kind of
old dusty republican
you would get an avalanche of
accusations of racism and xenophobia and
islamophobia and phobia phobia and you
would be and then you'd be buried in
that
but if you come out and say yeah she's a
member of the jihad squad and she loves
al qaeda
there's nothing you can't there's
nothing to come back at that with you're
so
confident you're so oh it's
it's like when you're trying to talk to
a girl when you're a teenager you're
trying to pick up a girl in high school
or something
you cannot if you go really timid and
she was like hey um hi there shelly um
would you like to maybe go to the prom
with me sometime i kind of like you for
a bit then you're going to seem weak and
you're going to get pulled over but if
you go and you say hey cutie you're
you're great i really like you a lot
let's go you and me let's go to the prom
together
you're just gonna seem more confident
and the lesson that's true of your
interpersonal life your lesson that's
true of just
personal social relations that's also
true in politics
and the other lesson from this is
we've got to do to the democrats what
they are doing to us nothing i'm not
saying we do something that is immoral
or unjust but as a matter of procedural
politics let's do the same thing nancy
pelosi is going to use a party-line vote
to strip republicans of their committees
okay well let's just do that to them
next time the minute the republicans
have the house which could be
sooner than the democrats expect let's
strip ilhan omar of her committees let's
strip
rashida talib and aoc and
all the rest of these radical let's
strip eric swalwell for sure of his
committees
let's do it why not they're doing it to
us
and the the left
responds
to force they respond to confidence they
respond to strength
okay and so let's use our political
force
let's strip them of their committees
let's mock them on the floor of the
house
well done
lauren bobert i'm glad you liked that
clip
subscribe
please please that would be great ring
the bell you will get the notifications
if you really want to guarantee you get
the notifications in the whole
uncensored show head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify or stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts that's the place to get it type
in the michael knowles show
leave a five-star review if you wouldn't
mind we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]